a two-part question for you
first have you received assurances that
you'll be able to to see through uh this
season as head coach
um i haven't
been reassured one way or the other now
okay and the second part is you know do
you do you feel like you're you know the
way that things are going that your your
job is in jeopardy uh you know at least
following this season
you know
listen i i've been around this league a
long time 25 years i believe as a player
and coach and
you know we're always based on and we're
evaluated on our performance and
right now that's obviously not my uh not
my concern as far as that decision goes
that's that's that's out of my hands but
what's in my hands and in my control is
getting the team prepared and ready
uh for uh you know for green bay uh this
weekend
i think it was fitting that as doug
peterson answered those questions the
super bowl trophy was looming over his
shoulder seriously right it was just
reminding me years ago just three years
ago that the eagles won it all but it
shows you how short the memories are and
how exacting the demands can be
especially once you've proven that you
can win a super bowl it's the kid who
brought home straight a's you can't just
bring straight a's home once the parents
develop an expectation the straight a's
are going to continue i could say i
brought it home every now and then i
brought it home and then i went back and
said ah i don't know but you're right i
know what you're saying you're right
there is that expectation and he set
expectations at a very high level
definitely there's there's no doubt
about that i do
do you think i i i'm one that says here
ago doug peterson on the hot seat to me
is crazy
crazy
i mean i i don't know any other way to
say it this year's not been good we
understand that we hit a lot on you know
hey carson wentz's struggles injury
issues we talked about hey the team
itself you know they might have held on
to that super bowl team shelf life just
one or two years too long and howie
roseman so it's bigger than doug
peterson but damn i mean
seven and nine super bowl
beat up after the super bowl make a run
get in the playoffs almost got the
saints in big trouble as the number one
seed in the nfc last year injuries again
battle get to the playoffs once again i
mean to me that's not even a discussion
i don't know how you feel about that
i don't think it should be a discussion
either especially since it's a crazy
upside down year and
we've never seen and i still keep
racking my brain for a quarterback who
came in with a high draft pedigree who
played well enough to get a second
contract and it's not like anyone was
saying carson wentz shouldn't get a
second contract i was saying jared goff
maybe shouldn't get a second contract
but i wasn't thinking that carson went
right shouldn't get a second contract
and then all of a sudden he's not the
guy that he was well what do you do
how do you process that you've got
financial restrictions that make it
impossible to move on from carson once
you have to try to make chicken salad
and the idea that the guy who's been to
the playoffs three straight years who
won a super bowl who almost got back to
the final four who somehow
with a five and second seven record last
year won the last four games of the
season got to the playoffs and could
have beaten the seahawks
but for the illegal hit that was neither
flagged nor fined when jadavian clowney
went in hot helmet first on carson wentz
and concussed him and they had to go
with josh mccown the rest of the way for
crying out loud we love josh mccown but
not a playoff game against the seahawks
we love him so uh
and the idea that this team which is
only a half game out of first place
that and the the the mere fact that
we're that we've arrived at the point in
the season
where a reporter will with a straight
face
ask those questions have you gotten an
assurance that you're going to be the
coach for the rest of the year
do you think that you're going to be the
coach beyond this season
i was stunned by that and uh you know
and and different coaches would have
reacted that differently i respect doug
peterson from telling that reporter to
cram in sideways frankly
but uh
but still i it's and that's that's look
part of that's philly
tough town
good ways and bad ways tough town and
you gave them a taste of the top of the
mountain they don't want to go back to
the bottom of it yeah well doug though
doug doug peterson's philly tough though
i really do believe that you know he he
doesn't give a damn you know his teams
show that they play philly tough too
they're always battling they they got
always have good energy you know despite
whether they're healthy or playing good
football i mean philadelphia always
comes to play and compete and is
physical
and
doug peterson's management of players
and how they play for them i mean i
think that's shown from the get-go in
philadelphia how much the team likes him
and respects him you know he's like andy
reid he never points fingers at players
he always blames himself and does those
things it's tough right now yeah it's
tough but i'm not like counting doug
peterson out in the big picture of
things of philadelphia going forward no
they fix a few things on that team and
they're healthy and with his coaching uh
and of course they got some talent on
defense i sit there and go no
philadelphia can turn this around in one
off season and be right back in the mix
next year
remember emotional intelligence was the
buzzword that jeffrey lurie was reciting
after he fired chip kelly who had
frankly no emotional intelligence and
hired doug peterson and i think that's
something that jeff lurie needs to keep
in mind as he considers his options
because ultimately it's his decision but
sometimes you want to be careful what
you wish for because sometimes
that new head coach
isn't gonna be
the guy that turns it around he's gonna
be worse it's gonna be more of a problem
and and look unless they are willing to
take a gigantic financial hit and pay
carson once a bunch of money to not play
for them and and take the cap hit in a
year
when the salary cap is only going to be
in the neighborhood of 175 million
well i just you'd be better off
supporting them
your alternative is
let's
see what happens next year and maybe
everyone's on notice next year and look
one one trend that has emerged in philly
andy reid missed the playoffs two
straight years he was gone chip kelly
missed the playoffs two straight years
he was gone so if they don't make it to
the playoffs this year
and they don't make it next year okay
fine if that's how jeff laurie wants to
run his team it's his prerogative you
fire your coach if he doesn't make it to
the playoffs two straight years so
that's that's kind of a high bar but if
that's what you do that's what you do
but i i just think it would be a huge
mistake
to completely forget about 2017 2018 and
2019. yeah i do too and and then like to
your point about the carson wentz thing
and getting rid of him and taking some
huge salary cap hit yeah i don't think
that's realistic first off i mean we
know doug peters and howie roseman they
they believe in carson wins they made
moves to get him so they're going to let
him he's got nine lives as far as the
eagles organization is considered and
carson wentz well he's got his own
issues he's got to adjust to philly life
and all that stuff too but i think their
best bet would be and a guy they believe
in hey let's fix some of the issues of
the team let's get some receivers a few
more weapons around here around the guy
and then we can make a decision after
the 2021 season to see if carson once is
still our guy either way but i can't
imagine that happening here you know
this or the 2022 season you know what
i'm saying there
it's amazing how quickly though an issue
can become a thing in the nfl and
i i think that the eagles are now under
this microscope for two reasons first
the report from the philadelphia
inquirer that jeffrey lurie left the
week 11 game between the didn't leave
didn't show up didn't even go boycotted
the browns eagles game because of his
frustration with the team and part of
that report from jeff mclean of the
philadelphia inquirer laurie has been
leaving practices in disgust this year
that's part of what has turned this up
and also the monday night game it became
open season on dysfunction between the
coaching staff and the front office open
season on harry rosen because one of the
broadcasters got fired by harry roseman
and never bothered to acknowledge that
when it was open season on harry roseman
which does kind of bother me i mentioned
it two days in a row now i just think if
you're going to bash somebody explain to
the audience that isn't up on all of the
relationships and histories yeah well
you know what the guy the guy did fire
me right so maybe maybe that's
influencing my
continued attack on the guy who once
fired me um so anyway it's a thing now
and and there's nothing like going into
green bay and beating the packers which
they did last year they did right this
is a blessing and a curse for the eagles
because last year they went in there and
won on a thursday night if they could do
it again this year
i think it ends all the talk if they
lose this year though you're gonna have
well last year you beat them and this
year you didn't so boy you really are
worse this year than you were last year
so uh it's an opportunity but it's it's
also if they if they just get
embarrassed in green bay it's gonna make
this chatter even louder i think chris
yeah i do too i mean i think they you
know again i'm not it's the nfl we know
it's a matchup league there's certain
things they match up well with with the
green bay packers but green bay for the
most part the way they execute and again
it just comes down to sheer manpower and
just not enough playmakers you know 97
different starting offensive linemen
arrangements this year all those issues
have just caught up to philadelphia and
that's made carson wentz press and
probably doug peterson's pressed and
it's just there there's issues i i just
don't see
them turning it around this year i
really don't i think this is one year
where yeah we're going to look back and
go damn you know that they ended up
eleven and one or you know five ten and
one and they got a that they got some
rebuilding to do
a couple of quick points before we take
a break first peterson declined to get
into any of his specific conversations
with the owner of the team jeffrey lurie
but peterson said they have a good
relationship it's always good until it
isn't that's kind of how it goes in the
nfl
as it relates though to this jalen hurts
issue we saw a couple of snaps from
hertz on monday night there was an
anticipation there would be more let's
let's listen to the exchange between
peterson and reporters on this question
of whether or not peterson was on board
with a second round pick being devoted
to the drafting of jalen hurts here it
is
were you on board with the jail hurts
draft pick when it happened
uh yes i was why
well yeah so because i'm wondering
because it hasn't really exactly played
out the way uh you guys originally at
least the way that originally said that
he would be utilized on offense and it
seems to have undermined uh
you to some extent and carson wentz
no i i don't i don't understand where
you're coming from you know because we
you know every year we look at we look
at quarterbacks every year we
uh if we have an opportunity to take a
quarterback we're going to take a
quarterback at least look at the
position i mean every position is is uh
uh looked at and and uh and studied and
wherever we can help and add talent and
depth
you know we're gonna do that and the
quarterback position is is not exempt
from that and and um you know this is a
this is a sport where there's only one
quarterback that plays and carson uh is
that is that player right now and
and uh and and we go to work and um
you know we we continue to coach jalen
and we get him prepared if he has to go
in and play
so much of what you do when you practice
law is study demeanor and delays and
facial expressions and
and gestures and
look i i i know that we've spent the
last 10 minutes or so saying that
everything's fine ultimately and they've
been good the last three years not this
year but 17 18 19 but i
that was a guy choosing his words very
very carefully and not trying to step
onto a land mine on this question of
whether he would definitely jalen hurt's
decision chris well it's it's a it's a
you know lightning rod topic i mean it
really is so you know everybody of
course when the team wins in every city
i mean the team loses in any city it's
the first thing is always bench to coach
and then you know bench the quarterback
bench the quarterback bench the
quarterback bench the quarterback you
know we need to play the backup we need
and then as jalen hurts who has been on
everybody's radar the last few years
because he was the quarterback at
alabama and the quarterback at oklahoma
and there's this storied you know
college programs and whoa they're good
and you know oh look he's the
quarterback and look at these numbers
he's putting up at oklahoma we need to
put him in there you know philadelphia
drafted him to be yeah a little bit of a
weapon
here probably in the first year or two
of his career and then hey maybe we you
know get a diamond in the rough at
quarterback where carson wentz we know
he's physical gets hurt a lot you know
maybe three four years down the road and
if we're not feeling the same about
carson wentz uh maybe jalen hurts can
turn into something and in the meantime
he can help out our offense and be a
weapon and do all those things the
problem is everybody in philadelphia
wants them to take over as a pure
quarterback and i think everybody in the
philly organization is trying to tell
the public without really saying it that
he's not ready to play quarterback but
nobody wants to take that and i think
that's really where the big issue is
more than anything right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports